c'est arsène wenger sur brut
[Musique]
je suis pas assez bon je vais le faire
plus tard
peut-être que je ne suis pas la hauteur
à partir du moment où vous aurez à mener
toutes les pensées négatives qui
viendront avec du style je peux je peux
pas je crains de engagez-vous totalement
quand vous aurez aimiez toutes les
pensées négatives
allez-y à fond et ne vous posez plus de
questions
[Musique]
les autres doivent être une source de
motivation mais pas de démotivation
si vous avez le potentiel pour remplir
les objectifs que vous faites fi xé que
vous êtes fixé la solution se trouve à
l'intérieur de chez vous donc il est
important de laisser de ne pas se
laisser distraire par des réactions
négatives venant des autres toute vérité
se trouve toujours à l'intérieur de vous
ce ne sont pas les autres qui peut faire
la vie à votre place
[Musique]
il faut si vous avez du talent le
combiné à l'effort
le talent sans l'effort ne mène à rien
mais pour cela il faut naturellement au
départ identifier ce qui n'a pas été
vous fixé un objectif et vous vous
entraînez pour naturellement maintenir
l'effort qui va me permettre d'arriver à
vos fins il faut savoir que l'effort a
souvent des effets lointain donc pendant
leurs périodes de l'effort
il ne faut pas céder et il faut
maintenir tout le temps votre votre
objectif et on maintient l'objectif en
sol en le soutenant avec les formes
il faut apprendre à maîtriser ses peurs
par ces les peurs sans rien dimitris et
maîtriser ses peurs ses ne pas être dans
le doute
ce n'est pas il ya toujours une partie
du cerveau qui veulent qui vous dis on
je veux y arriver au peut-être je vais
pas y arriver et non vous êtes dans
l'hésitation
c'est cela pire le cerveau de celui qui
remplit ses objectifs et m on t'a ce
qu'il est concentré il est dans le
présent il est dans l'action et dans le
plat concentration sur l'acte affaire il
n'est pas dans l'hésitation
[Musique]
côté négatif c'est la déception de la
défaite elle est tout à fait logique
et là la blessure elle vous fait tout à
fait mal et c'est tout à fait logique
si une défaite ne vous fait pas mal
c'est qu'on n'a pas beaucoup de chance
de vous améliorer
mais il faut analyser objectivement la
différence entre les genres qui gagne et
ceux qui perdent c'est pas que les gens
qui gagnent n'ont jamais connu des fêtes
c'est que ils ont analysé de façon très
objective leur performance en étant un
peu dur avec eux mêmes et ont surtout je
pense puis et puis puiser de l'énergie
pour corriger leurs et fender leurs
défauts et je pense que c'est là qu'il
faut être le plus adulte et ne rejetait
pas la faute sur les autres les
événements extérieurs
l'explication se trouve souvent à
l'intérieur de vous et c'est là qu'il
faut déceler ce qui vous a manqué et
revenir à ce moment là beaucoup plus
fort